Three eunuchs on the panel right now.
Jacob, Alfie, Conleth, do you guys have a support group?
How does it work, you know?
Well we have an arts and crafts group
so we've made various ornaments with our,
you know, we've got earrings
(laughter)
cufflinks, a couple of cufflinks
and one of us has supplied a couple of door stops,
that's all I'm saying.
Well Alfie, I've gotta ask you because
you've actually decided to go with it,
when you sign an autograph, you do it in a special way
that's sort of a tribute to what many people
know about your character.
Yeah, I mean, people seem to really like it.
They ask me to sort of draw
a severed penis on my autograph.
[Conan] As your autograph?
Not as my autograph just...
Oh I thought when you were like writing a check
you write your name and then there's
a chopped off dick at the end.
That's what I thought.
(Cheering)
I don't...
Let me tell you this, no ones gonna forge that, you know?
My hand just started to get tired, what can I say?